[موسيقى]
دشنت فرنسا تدخلها العسكري في مالي بقصف
جوي مكثف نفذته ضد المتمردين في معركه
استعاده مدينه كونا للسيطره الحكوميه
وياتي التدخل الفرنسي قبل ايام من وصول
قوات من دول غرب افريقيا المعروفه اختصارا
بالاكوا ينتظر ان تشارك ايضا في الصراع
الدائري في مالي منذ عده
اشهر
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من زاويتين ما
مدى وجهه التحليلات التي استندت عليها
باريس في تبرير تدخلها في مالي وما هي
الوجهه التي يمكن ان ياخذها هذا الصراع
بعد انخراط الفرنسيين
[موسيقى]
فيه
اسعد الله
اوقاتكم الصراع الذي عصف بجمهوريه مالي
اشهرا عده دخل منذ الجمعه الماضي مرحله
ليست كما قبلها وفق وجهه نظر الكثيرين اما
الحد الفاصل في تطور هذا الصراع فهو
التدخل العسكري الفرنسي في معركه استعاده
مدينه كونا من ايدي المتمردين حسمت
المعركه لصالح القوات الحكوميه لكن فرنسا
قدمت ايضا في هذه المعركه اول خسائرها
البشريه بمقتل احد
طيارها تواصل القوات الفرنسيه عملياتها
العسكريه الداعمه للحكومه الماليه ضد
المسلحين القادمين من الشمال وذلك ضمن خطه
بدا تنفيذها يوم الجمعه تستهدف ايقاف
تقدمهم نحو الجنوب باتجاه العاصمه وبقيه
اجزاء البلاد الواقعه تحت سيطره حكومه
الرئيس ديون كوند تراوري ثم الحيلوله دون
اقامه دوله ارهابيه على مقربه من اوروبا
على حد التعبير
الفرنسي استطاعت القوات بالفعل حسب روايه
باريس قطع الطريق امام اولئك المعارضين من
خلال محور محيط بلده كونا مع تامين بلده
سيفاري التي تعتبر بوابه العاصمه باماكو
وتبعد عنها نحو 500 ر بينما انتشرت القوات
الفرنسيه في باماكو وضواحيها لحمايه
السكان المحليين وتامين نحو 6000 مواطن
فرنسي موجودين هناك
فرنسا هي الدوله الاولى غربيا وافريقيا
التي تدخلت في مالي وتبدا دول المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا ايكواس ارسال
جنودها لمالي يوم الاثنين لتنفيذ المهمه
المعلنه عبر مختلف المنابر الدوليه
والافريقيه وهي انهاء احتلال شمال مالي من
قبل الجماعات المسلحه التابعه للطوارق
الانفصاليين وانصار تنظيم القاعده
والمعروف ان هذه الجماعات بمسمياتها
المختلفه استولت على شمال مالي منذ
الانقلاب الذي اطاح برئيس البلاد المخضرم
اماد التومان التوري في مارس الماضي هي
البدايه لكن مؤشرات النهايه تظل ضبابيه
فرغم ان الايكواس دعت منذ شهور لتشكيل
تحالف عسكري افريقي ودولي لتحرير شمالي
مالي الا ان فرنسا هي الدوله الغربيه
الوحيده التي استجابت بطريقتها واحج
الشركاء الاخرون وسط شكوك وخلافات تتعلق
بالتمويل والتفويض
ومع ذلك فان الهدف واضح وبدا تنفيذه ولكن
اذا تحقق فان كثيرين لا يرون في ذلك نهايه
لتهديد القاعده وحلمها بقيام دوله في
المنطقه ولا نهايه لحلم الطوارق بقيام
دولتهم هناك قد تتفرق فلولهم في تخوم
المنطقه الشاسعه التي يعرفونها ولكنهم قد
يتحينون الفرص لتحقيق هدفهم بعد خروج
المتدخلين ومع وجود مثل هذا الاحتمال الذي
يدركه الفرنسيون وغيرهم جيدا هل سينسحبون
من مالي بعد انقضاء المهمه الراهنه في حال
انتهائها اصلا ام سيطول بقائهم بحجه
مطارده القاعده والقضاء
عليها ومعنا في هذه الحلقه من واك شوت
محمد محمود ابو المعالي الخبير في
الجماعات المسلحه في الساحل والصحراء
ومعنا ايضا من العاصمه الفرنسيه برونو
ترتر الباحث في مؤسسه البحث الاستراتيجي
في باريس اهلا بضيفي لو بدانا بباريس وسيد
ترتر ما مدى وجاهه ما قدمته فرنسا لتبرير
هذا التدخل في
مالي اعتقد ان ما يبرر هذا التدخل هو ان
الجهاديين قد فاجئوا العالم برمته مؤخرا
باطلاق هجوم سريع نحو الجنوب
وربما يعرفون كانوا يعرفون ان هناك تدخل
عسكري كان يعد له ولكن ذلك كان من شاني ان
يكون تدخلا متعدد الجنسيات قد يطلب اشهر
عديده لذلك اراد هؤلاء ان يستفيدوا او
يستغلوا من حيث ان التدخل الافريقي متعدد
الجنسيات لا يمكن ان يحصل او تحقق قبل
مرور اشهر عديده فارادوا ان يستفيدوا من
هذه الفرصه من ذلك فان الخيار امام فرنسا
كان اما ان لا يفعلوا اي شيئا مع خطر
التاثير
وساء الى السياده الاقليميه لمالي وتحدت
جميع الماليين وكذلك رعايا الفرنسيين هناك
او القيام بتدخل عسكري طارئ لم يكن هو ما
تتمناه باريس لان باريس كانت تفضل ان تدعم
تدخل افريقي ومتعدد الجنسيات ولكن مي في
وضع صعب جدا وقلق بحيث لم تستطع ان تعار
تقاوم بحيث اصبح تدخلنا الاجنبي مشروعا
خاصه وان الرئيس المالي قد طالب ذلك سيد
ترتر اكثر
كلمه تكررت على السنه المسؤولين الفرنسيين
هي محاربه الارهاب في في مالي هل يمكن ان
يكون هذا سببا مقنعا للراي العام
الدولي
من وجهه نظر المجتمع الدولي ليس هناك اي
غموض او جهل ذلك ان العالم كله
وخاصه افريقيا قد اعلنت بشكل واضح بانها
تؤيد جميعا تدخل عسكري متعدد الجنسيات
ولكن موضوع الارهاب والخطر الذي يمثله
الارهاب ضد اوروبا وحتى ضد افريقيا خاصه
تنظيم القاعده في بلاد المغرب الاسلامي
ليس هذا فقط السبب هناك ايضا مساله حمايه
سياده دوله مستقله وحمايه المدنيين وايضا
وجود الارهابيين ووجود مختطفين ورهاء
فرنسيين اضافه الى المصالح الاقتصاديه
الاوروبيه نعم اذا اخذنا في الاعتبار بان
الجماعات المسلحه هناك سيد ابو المعالي
بادرت بهذا الهجوم لانها كانت تتوقع ان ان
تاتيها الضربه قريبا هل تراها اخطات في
هذا التوج
طيب شكرا جزيلا الواضح ان الجماعات
الاسلاميه المسلحه المسيطر على ازواد حين
ادركت انه لا مناص من الحرب ولا ما فر
منها وان باريس تعد لحرب على نار هادئه
حرب كان يتوقع ان تخوضها فرنسا بجيوش
افريقيه مدعومه بسلاح الجو الفرنسي
وبالدعم ارادت الحركات الاسلاميه المسيطره
وفي مقدمتها حركه انصار الدين ان تربك
المخطط الفرنسي وان تدفع الى تدخل غير
مدروس بحيث لا تكون نتائجه مضمونه بل
بالعكس قد تكون عواقبه وخيمه ارادت ايضا
ان تدفع بالفرنسيين الى ان يوجدو هم
انفسهم على الميدان بدل ان يكون لهم وكلاء
من الافارقه وطالما سعت هذه الجماعات الى
استدراج الغربيين الى المنطقه لتصطدم عن
قرب اعتقد ان حركه انصار الدين والقاعده
والتوحيد والجهاد والحركات المتحالفه معها
نجحت فعلا في استدراج الفرنسيين وفي ارباك
الخطه بحيث انه لم يعد بد امام الفرنسيين
من التدخل ميدانيا اذ ان القوات الافريقيه
غير جاهزه و وبامكان الاسلاميين ان يصلوا
الى بامكو ان انتظرت فرنسا التدخل
الافريقي ولكن اسمح لي الرئيس الرئيس
الفرنسي اسمح لي سيد ابو المعالي الرئيس
الفرنسي قال بانه تم ايقاف تقدم هذه
القوات نحو باماكو وايضا موضوع الارهاب
الذي اشار اليه اليه المسؤولون الفرنسيون
تردد ايضا على السنه مسؤولين اخرين البيت
الابيض قال بانه يساند فرنسا في مكافحه
الارهاب حتى روسيا على
لسان مسؤولها الخاص بافريقيا قال بان هذه
المنطقه تحولت الى بؤره للارهاب والجريمه
المنظمه برايك هذه الجماعات هل اصبحت الان
محل اجماع دولي تقريبا وليس فقط فرنسي
لمكافحتها التنديد بهذه الجماعات ورفضها
دوليا ليس ب امر الجديد منذ سيطرتها على
زواد بل دعني اقول لك منذ وجود القاعده
فرع القاعده ببلاد المغرب الاسلامي في
منطقه زواد بدايه ال000 بدا العالم يتدمر
بدا يشكو بدا يعلن رفضه لكن هذا الرفض ما
زال في غالبه الاعم رفضا كلاميا رفضا
قوليا لاج لا يوجد اي تدخل عملي باستثناء
ما حصل الان ما قامت به فرنسا وانا اعتقد
ان الفرنسيين وقعوا من حيث لا يدرون في
شراكه هذه الجماعات اذ دفعوها الى اذ
دفعوا الجيش الفرنسي الى ان ينزل على
الميدان ليصطاد وفعلا فرنسا بدات تدفع
النتائج منذ اليوم الاول جنديان سقطا
مروحيتان هذا في معركه بلده كونا الخارسه
اصلا عن ازواد والتي لا تمثل اي قيمه
استراتيجيه اللهم الا اذا كانت الخطوط
الاماميه لدفاع الجيش المالي ليس الا ترى
ما هو الثمن الذي سيدفعه الفرنسيون لو
حاولوا التقدم شمالا نحو تمبوكتو وجاو
وباقي المدن الاخرى نعم ه هذه هذه ربما
هذه ايضا هذه ربما من المخاطر التي يمكن
ان تترتب على توسع هذا النزاع او التورط
الفرنسي فيه ولكن سيد ترتر عندما عندما
يقول الرئيس فرانسوا اولاند بان التدخل
الفرنسي وهنا اقتبس مما قال هو لمواجهه
اعتداء لعناصر ارهابيه يعلم الجميع اجمع
وحشيتها وتطرف بالنسبه ل
المتابعه خارج هذه المنطقه ربما السؤال
الاكثر الحاح ما دخل فرنسا في مكافحه
الارهاب في هذه البقعه من افريقيا
تحديدا ش اود اولا اذا ما سمحتم لي ان ارد
باختصار على ما قاله زميلك الضيف الاخر
اذا ما كان المجاهد القاعده وغيرهم
يعتقدون ان فرنسا وقع
فهم مخون خط كبيرا فاولا اعتقد ان هذا
التدخل لم يحصل بشكل سريع و بشكل خفيف
وثانيا ليس هناك تدخل او ارضي كبير الامر
يتعلق
باستخدامه بالهجوم على هذه المنطقه
لايقاف تحرك
واندفاع الجهاديين نحو الجنوب وبالتالي
يعني يؤكد ان هذا الدخل سيبقى خفيفا ولا
اعتقد ان فرنسا سقطت في فخ وهنا اذكر بان
التدخل كان ناجحا اما فيما يتعلق بما
يفعله الفرنسي هناك فاود ان اذكر مره اخرى
بان القاعده في المغرب الاسلامي قد اعلنت
انها عدوه فرنسا فرنسا لن تعلن الحرب
عليها بل ان القاعده في المغرب الاسلامي
هي التي اعلنت الحرب على فرنسا قبل اربع
او خمس سنوات وبالتالي من ذلك الوقت نحن
في موقف مواجهه معهم مجاه مع هؤلاء الذين
لا يهاجمون فقط المصالح الماليه بل ايضا
المصالح الفرنسيه والرعايا الفرنسيين في
مالي والنيجر وغدا قد يعدون لهجمات على
الاراضي الفرنسيه وبالتالي فان موقف فرنسا
واضح حتى الا ان هذا التدخل لن يتحدد
بمكافحه الارهاب فقط نعم لكن سيد ترتر
مثلا المبعوث الروسي لافريقيا سيد ميخائيل
مرجوف يقول بان تدخل كتدخل الفرنسي يفترض
ان يتم باشراف من الامم المتحده او من
الاتحاد الافريقي فرنسا حاولت ان تبرر هذا
التدخل استنادا لميثاق الامم المتحده هل
تعتقد بان هذا التبرير يمكن ان يقف على
رجليه و نعم ول سببين اولا لان هناك فعلا
عدد من القرارات من مجلس الامن الي تعطي
اطارا قانوني وشرعيه للتدخل في مالي
واضافه لذلك ايضا اذكر بان هناك حق الدفاع
الشرعي عن نفسه المذكور في ميثاق الامم
المتحده وهنا ايضا الامر يتعلق بطلب
مساعده من مالي وبالتالي بامكان فرنسا ان
تتدخل بشكل مشروع
ونتيجه طلب من البلد المالي وبالتالي
ففرنسا لم تفعل سوى المشاركه في الدفاع
المشروع عن مالي بالنسبه يعتقد ان الاطار
الشرعي والقانوني لهذا التدخل لا يشكل اي
مشكله اليوم اذا ما تحول التدخل بشكل جذري
وهو ما لا اعتقد انه سيكون ضمن نوايا
الفرنسيين فذلك الامر انذاك سيختلف ولكن
اليوم ما يقوم به الجيش الفرنسي اليوم لا
يبدو لي ان يشكل اي مشكله من الناحيه
القانونيه او الشرعيه مع ذلك يظل السؤال
ما اذا كانت فرنسا بتدخلها هذا ستحسم
الامور لصالح الحكومه الماليه ام ان ربما
ياخذ منحى اخر في المستقبل هذا ما سنعود
للتطرق اليه بعد هذا الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام مازلتم
معنا في هذه الحلقه التي نناقش فيها
اتجاهات السراع في مالي بعد تدخل العسكري
الفرنسي هناك سيد ابو المعالي برايك الى
اين يمكن ان يسير هذا التدخل الفرنسي
الان طيب شكرا جزيلا قبل الرد على سؤالك
انا اعتقد ان محاوله التلبيس الاخلاقي او
اضفاء مسحه اخلاقيه على تدخل الفرنسي هو
نوع من المزايده درج عليه الغرب برمته اذ
كلما اراد حمايه مصالحه البسها ثوبا
اخلاقيا والا لما
كان لما غاب هذا التدخل عن الكدير من
الازمات التي فتك بها بالكثيرين وعيس في
الارض فسادا لان مصالح غربيه توجد فيها
ردا على سؤالك الى اين تتجه الامور انا
اعتقد ان ما يجري هو تعقيد عسكري وليس حلا
عسكريا الامور تتجه نحو التصعيد نحو مزيد
من الانفجار يعني نحو الحرب وتوابعها حرب
لم يعدلها جيدا
الفرنسيون ارادوا من وراء تدخل سريع منع
سقوط العاصمه باماكو و عدم تكرار التجربه
الصوماليه في غياب الدوله المركزيه لكنهم
نسوا ان اي تدخل عسكري غير مدروس وغير
محكم انما هو نوع من تجذير الصوم باعتبار
ان ما يحصل في
ال اق غير مدروس افريقيه غير
حاس في هذا الوضع نعم اسمحلي يعني كلمه
غير مدروس قد لا تكون هي المناسبه لان
الموضوع التدخل العسكري مطروح منذ اشهر
ووقع الخوض فيه واجتماعات وافريقيه
وفرنسيه افريقيه ودول الجوار وصفرا الى
الجزائر وغيرها يعني التدخل طبخ على نار
هادئه يمكن
القول لا كان قيد الطبخ على نار هادئه لكن
الحركات الاسلاميه استعجلت الفرنسيين
والافارقه ودفعتهم الى تدخل التدخل كان
يتوقع ان يبدا في شهر سبتمبر من هذا العام
اي بعد عده اشهر هذا التحرك نحو الجنوبي
الذي قامت به قوات انصار الدين والحركات
المتحالفه معها دفع الفرنسيين الى تدخل
والافارقه بداوا في ارسال قواتهم على عجل
اذا هو اربك الخطه واستعجل التدخل قبل
اوانه وبالتالي محاوله لاصطياد
المتدخلين ودفعهم الى المستنقع ال الزوادي
قبل ان يكونوا جاهزين وقبل اكتمال العده
فعلا اتخذ القرار بدا بدات دراسه المنطقه
بدا الخبراء في الوجود في باماكو بل في
سفاري لكن لم تكن هناك قوه جاهزه ومعده و
لم ترسل حتى الان وبدا ارسالها على عجل
وبدا ايضا ارسالها لا للاستعداد وانما
للدخول في الحرب بشكل مباشر ولكن هذا هذا
مبدئيا سيد ابو المعالي مبدئيا هذا مستبعد
وهنا اسال سيد ترتر لان فرنسا على لسان
قائد عسكري هناك قال
نحن نريد
ايقاف زحف المتمردين
وليس الدخول معهم في معركه لتحرير شمال
مالي هل هذه هي الرؤيه الفرنسيه
الان و نعم نعم هذا بالضبط هو ان هدف
العمليه الجاريه حاليا والتي بدات يوم امس
هي فعلا ذات هدف محدود الا وهو احتواء
اندفاع وتقدم القوات الجهاديه نحو الجنوب
وان مساله تدخل مستقبلي متعدد الجنسيات
اكث اقوى من ذلك لتحرير الشمال المالي ما
زال قائما و محتملا العمليه الحاليه حسب
رايي ليست بديلا حس عن هجوم او عمليه
متعدد جنسيات تجري
مستقبلا معظمها من الافارقه ستجري في شمال
مالي كله ولكن مره اخرى اقول ان هذا
التدخل في المستقبل لا يمكن نتوقع حصوله
قبل عده اشهر لانه قبل كل شي ان القوات
الافريقيه وخاصه ابتداء بالمالي غير
مستعدين حاليا للدخول في معارك وبالتالي
فان حاليا ان ضعف القوات الماليه التي
اجبرت فرنسا بشكل ما الى التدخل وان الخطر
كان اذا لم يكن هناك ايقاف ومعارضه لهذه
الحركه وتوجه الجهادي نحو
الجنوب فان ذلك يعني انهم سيتوصل
الى الى العاصمه نعم سيد ترتري هل هناك
مجازفه فيما يتعلق بالخسائر التي قد
تتكبدها فرنسا لان البعض اشار ان التدخل
الفرنسي في ليبيا مثلا طوال سبعه اشهر لم
تخسر فرنسا جنديا واحدا او ضابطا واحدا في
حين في مالي منذ اليوم الاول خسر التيار
هل هذا
وارد وون نعم نعم انت محق فيضيح ان الحرب
في ليبيا ولحسن حظ الجيش الفرنسي لم يؤدي
الى مقتل اي جندي فرنسي ولكن كل تدخل
عسكري فيه خطر وفيه احتمال بالنسبه لكل
المشاركين فيه نساء رجالا ان يسقط ضحايا
فيهم وان الرئيس كان يعرف ذلك وان الجيش
كان مستعد لقبول هذه
المجازفه لكن لو حصلت نتائج جيده نتيجه
العمليه فان الراي العام الفرنسي مستعد
لقبول هذا هذه التضحيه واعتقد ان خطر
محدود نسبيا بالنسبه للجنود الفرنسيين
اليوم نظرا لان الامر يتعلق بعمليه خفيفه
نسبيا عدد الطائرات والمروحيات فيها محدود
وقد واعتقد انه حتى لو حصل قتله اخرى فان
الراي العام الفرنسي مستعد لقبول هذا
الخطر والاحتمال اذا ما وجد ان ذلك مفيدا
لمالي ولافرق واوروبا ولفرنسا هذا الخطر
المحدود سيد ابو المعالي هل يعود ايضا الى
درجه كب الى ان هذه الجماعات الاسلاميه
المسلحه هناك تقريبا معزوله يعني هي كل
دول الجوار خائفه منها وتحاول الحد من
تاثيرها وهناك اجماع دولي على ضروره
محاربتها والان هناك شبه اجماع دولي
واقليمي على وجاهه التدخل العسكري لضربها
اذا امكانيه التورط او استمرار هذا النزاع
يبدو مبدئيا
مستبعدا انا لا اعتقد ان الامر على هذه
الصوره ابدا وان الوضع في ازواد بكل تاكيد
ليس باماني الفرنسيين ولا باماني الماليين
ولا بدول الجوار الوضع في ازواد اكثر
تعقيدا هناك هذه الجماعات التي تجري
محاربتها والتي اسست وجودها على مظالم
تاريخيه ومطالب تاريخيه لسكان المنطقه
الفرنسيون اكدوا انهم سيرسلون الاف الجنود
او مئات الجنود الى بامكو لحمايه العاصمه
هؤلاء الجنود لن يكونوا بمن
من ايادي القاعده ومن ايادي الجماعات
المسلحه المصالح الفرنسيه برمتها في
المنطقه لن تكون
بمفازتهم للقاعده ناهك عن الرهائن
الفرنسيين الموجودين في قبضه القاعده انا
اعتقد ان التدخل الفرنسيه وسقوط مروحيتين
ومقتل جندي وجنديين ليس الا بدايه المشوار
لنتائج هذا التدخل و لا اوافق ضيفكم
الكريم بان التدخل ربما زال بالامكان
ومحتمل لا التدخل بدا القوات التي يجري
الاعداد حاليا لارسالها من النيجر من
بركينا فاسو من ساحل العاج هي ذاتها
القوات التي كان يجري الحديث عن تحضيرها
في اطار التدخل لاستعاده ازواد اذا الحرب
بدات وا او ارغم الافارقه والفرنسيون على
بدئها قبل موعدها وبالتالي قبل التحضير
الكافي لها نعم و ولكن ولكن اسمح لي سيد
ابو المعالي هل اسمح لي هل هل هل نجح
الفرنسيون في تاليب العالم كله على هؤلاء
المتمردين المسلحين لان مثلا عندما يقول
السيد لورون فابيوس وزير الخارجيه بانه
لاول مره هناك خطر ان يسيطر ارهابيون على
دوله في افريقيا اذا في هذه الحاله
امكانيه توظيف هذا العنصر في مالي من قبل
فرنسا يبدو ناجحا لحد الان على
الاقل تاليب العالم على هذه الجماعات اصلا
امر قائم الكل يرفضها والكل يخشاها وهي
جماعات تصنف عالميا بانها جماعات ارهابيه
وبعضها يصنف كجماعات انفصاليه ضد الدوله
المركزيه في مالي وبالتالي العالم تقريبا
برمته يرفضها لكن من يقبل بالتدخل
لمواجهتها على الميدان الافارقه وحدهم
الاكواس اعلنوا انهم يقبلون بالتدخل هذا
التدخل انا اؤكد لك ان حصل يعني ان مجازره
سترتكب ذات طابع عرقي ضد سكان الشمال يعني
ان القوات القادمه ستحارب في بيئه لا
تعرفها القوات الافريقيه قوات درج ج ت على
التدرب والحرب في الادغال وعلى الضفاف
والشطان ولم تالف الصحراء وزواد صحراء
واسعه انتشار ايضا ستجد في مواجهتها
جماعات غير اسلاميه وغير سلفيه من قبيل
الحركه الوطنيه لتحرير الزواد والجبهه
العربيه لتحرير الزواد ستجد كتله من
المظالم ستجد ايضا تضاريس وصحاري ستقع في
فخها ايضا الفرنسيون سيكونون في متناول
هذه الجماعات ستصطدم
من حيث ارادت وسترهم الى ارض معركه هي من
حددتها لاهم من حددوها شكرا لك سيد محمد
محمود ابو المعالي الخبير في الجماعات
المسلحه في الساحل والصحراء كنت معنا من
واك شوت شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس برونو ترتر الباحث في
مؤسسه البحث الاستراتيجي في باريس بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا